want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some incredible motivation
from warren buffett
enjoy
[Music]
if you were to do it all over again
you're in our shoes
what industry would that be in where
would you start your own business today
i'd do the same thing yeah i mean
but one thing i'd be a failure to
anything else probably i'm not gonna
no i mean i've had i had fun when i was
in my 20s my 30s now i'm 86 i'm having
fun and so
i i advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleepwalk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not a
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain
you really want to be doing what you
love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it you
don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god you know you don't need 140
you know 135 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing in
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets the
two strikes
in business you don't have to swing at
anything you can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called
strikes and you can simply wait for that
one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years
when you really know what you're doing
where you like the price or you like the
people running the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime how do you
deal with failure
and what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs like me in this case
especially with regards to failure and
how to approach it yeah well
if you fail you really do dust yourself
off and you know get right back in
i mean you're going to fail at some
things uh
uh you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out
uh you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced i mean
you know that's a very big decision to
have turned out badly but
uh i think if you study
almost everybody and read read case book
you know personal history
and you'll everybody fails at some
things right
you know particularly particularly when
you're younger i mean you know you do
have less experience in evaluating
humans and you know and and just
knowing about whatever maybe businesses
uh
but you know it is not fatal i mean if
you're healthy
and you live in this particular living
in this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was
uh when i got out of the university
nebraska you know and i remember you
know
i went to chicago to get interviewed
this is when you traveled on the train
and so i spent 10 hours going there and
this fellow looked at me and
about 10 minutes he said you know forget
it bell wow
and now i've got to go back on the train
10 hours maybe oh no what am i going to
talk
about it tell my dad i mean my dad
always told me i could do anything
right now i've just got just gotten
turned down uh you know
but it turned out that one of the best
things ever happened to me because then
i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact it probably
even affected who i married because i
took a one-year course at columbia and
said two years at harvard and she might
have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
but usually it's turned into a success i
mean that it
the world isn't over you know if you
have bad luck in health
that that's tough i mean there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but
but the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and
you know you got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out
and find somebody else also if you want
to have more self-confidence and
self-belief i've created
a special free program called 254
because the sign says that it takes up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a habit
so what i'm gonna do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below investing in yourself is the best
thing you can do anything that improves
your own talents
nobody can take it away from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
become worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
it's important to associate with people
that are
better than yourself they made us all
these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things you
haven't bought the stock
you're an admirer of jeff bezos a
listing of the richest
people in america came out he's number
one i think your friend bill gates is
number two you're number three
so you can see what he's done in myriad
ways
and of course the question is how come
you haven't bought amazon is there still
time to buy would you still buy well i
i always admired jeff i mean i met him
20 years ago or so and and and
i thought it was something special but i
didn't realize you could go from books
to what
what's happened there no i i mean he had
a vision
and executed in an incredible way
something that
it would not have you know that
but there's a lot of games i miss i
would have missed you know i would have
missed microsoft even if i'd gotten to
know bill
earlier or something those just aren't
my games i don't worry about the things
that
i miss that are outside my circle of
confidence of evaluating
i did i do i have missed things that
were within my circle
and that's a terrible mistake those are
my biggest mistakes
you haven't seen them and but i don't
it's not a mistake because i miss
netscape or something like that at all
i would say that maybe five percent of
the companies or ten percent of the
companies that most
are within an area my circle of
confidence there's something i shouldn't
be able to understand warren is probably
the most rational
person i've ever met charlie munger
would be a close
rival and charlie became a man
that warren depended on heavily
and i think his first experiences in the
discarded cigar butt era convinced him
that it was not
exactly where he wanted to be he'd made
so much money for so long doing what
he'd been taught by ben graham
which should buy these very cheap stocks
if they were cheap enough he didn't care
it was a lousy company and lousy
management he
knew he was going to make money anyway
just because of the cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices
rather than fair companies at wonderful
prices and that was enormously important
because it enabled berkshire to scale up
in a way that would have been impossible
to do otherwise
[Music]
we were metal partners right from the
moment we met
[Music]
i want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first
met warren well i thought he was a
prodigy
and i got a lot of criticism my wife
said why are you paying such enormous
respect to that young man with a crew
cut who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into
just a very few words if you're not
interested in the economic
scene right now you're mentally dead
charlie has no tax all right let's talk
a little bit about bankers
charlie on friday compared them to
heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful charlie but i
would not have chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility
he didn't get his fair share the ideal
way to run a headquarters is to have
one man preferably over 80
sitting in an office by himself
anything else is pure flippery
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listened to him
[Applause]
we never had an argument we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what the hell difference does it make to
me
net the record is working out fine how
do i value the business as berkshire
acquires well
the first thing i have to decide when
somebody calls me is
is valuing this business within my
circle of competence
i don't know how to value microsoft i
don't know how to value oracle i mean if
you know larry ellison calls me or bill
gates calls me and they don't
but if any of those i don't know or
biotech or anything i wouldn't know how
to value it i just
you know i'd wish them well and tell
them you know i think it's worth twice
as much as they think it is but i'm just
not
in the mood to buy today uh i i don't
know
so it has to be within my circle of
confidence my circle of confidence is
you know businesses i can understand
when i say understand
i don't mean to understand how to use a
computer and not use a computer in terms
of a computer company
i mean understand what the economic
characteristics of the business are
and what the company's really going to
look like in five or 10 or 20 years
bill gates will tell you that that he
you know if he were investing he would
buy
berkshire rather than microsoft because
it's so much easier
to understand what our businesses are
going to look like whereas he's in a
business where you're going to really
have to be doing things differently over
time
so i know that wrigley's going to be the
number one chewing gum
in the country i know stickers are going
to be the number one candy bar in the
country 10 years now
it's been the number one candy bar for
40 years you don't have to be
very bright to understand that when
people lay out 50 cents for something
that they stick in their mouth that
they're not about to experiment you know
i mean
it's so we we try to look at businesses
we can understand
if you buy a business if you buy a farm
you know
you go up and look you know every couple
weeks to see how far the corn is up and
you know you worry too much about
whether somebody says this is going to
be a year low prices because
exports are being affected or anything
like that you know you buy a farm
and you hold it for i've got one farm
that i bought in the 1980s and
my son runs it but i've been there once
you know i mean it it it doesn't grow
faster if i go and stare at it you know
i can't cheer for it you know
more effort more effort or something
like that and i know there's going to be
some years when prices are going to be
good and some when the prices aren't
going to be good i know there's years
when yields will be better than others
what about the farm and and uh
if it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions
or anything of the sort i do care that
over over the years it's well tended to
in terms of rotating crops and
i hope yields get better which they
generally have in fact
that farm 100 years ago would have
probably produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices
go back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better at
whether it's cotton or whether it's it's
corn or soybeans or all kinds of things
and you and i have benefited from that
and so apple's
kind of like a farm well it's a it's a
long term
investment and and if you owned
if you own the the best auto dealership
in town
the best brand and they had somebody
good running
you wouldn't drop by every day and say
you know how many people have come in
today or
you know i think interest rates are
going up a little maybe that'll slow
down our sales or anything
no you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and
you're going to own it for 20 years so
that's 7 300 days and you know they're
gonna
things are going to be different from
day to day and year to year
you shouldn't buy it if the day-to-day
stuff is important you both have several
managers working under you so i was
wondering what
are some steps that a new entrant into
the job market can take to
accelerate their journey towards an
upper level management position
yeah well one thing i will tell you that
i didn't realize when i was
getting out of school is how much the
unusual person
will jump out at you i mean you know and
it isn't because they got
200 iqs or anything like that it's
really because just how they behave
you know what they bring the energy they
bring the commitment they bring the
quality of how they do things how they
treat the people around them all kinds
of things but
you will jump out much more than you
might anticipate
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do uh
is whether you like it or not get very
comfortable it may take a while with
public speaking for example i mean that
that's a an asset that will last you 50
or 60 years and it's a liability
if you don't like doing it or
uncomfortable doing it that also will
last you fifty or six years and it's a
necessary skill
but a lot of the skills are just human
skills if you get the best out of people
around you
that's a rare talent and it it doesn't
it doesn't correlate with iq it
correlates with a
you know an attitude and uh toward the
world and toward other people and
it's a talent that if you work at early
and you're really conscious about it
you know you don't have to show up other
people you know you have to be smart in
there or anything
you want to bring out the best in them
it will pay huge dividends
it is always being ahead of the game
rather than getting behind the game it's
saving a little no matter how you do it
i mean i
delivered papers i worked at pennies i
sold golf balls i had a pinball machine
round i did a lot of things that enabled
me to accumulate about ten thousand
dollars by the time i got out of school
uh ten thousand doesn't go as far now as
it did then but it
having anything so that you're ahead of
the game and not getting behind
the game is enormously important i mean
just
you know if you're going to run 100 100
yard dash against
a bunch of people in life if you can
figure it out so that when the gun goes
off you're 10 or 15 yards ahead
instead of 10 or 15 yards behind it's
going to make an enormous difference in
how that race comes out so
having having some net resources
doesn't make much difference whether
they're in stocks or bonds in my view
but
and not having debt when that gun goes
off when you get out of school
uh is a huge plus over being behind the
game and uh
you know it may come from delivering a
paper out in the morning it may come
from part-time work someplace but but
put aside a few dollars for yourself but
uh
so that when the time comes and you
enter you enter the workforce
you're ahead of the game and not behind
and then once you get there don't get
behind by buying a whole lot of things
that
you figure you're going to pay for some
day while you're paying 20 interest in
between
i like to read more than most kids i
really like to read a lot
my aunt edie gave me a copy of the world
almanac
and that was heaven to me and i can
still tell you that almost population
was 214
0006 in 1930. some numbers just kind of
stick with you
and very early probably when i was seven
or so i took this book out of the
benson library called a thousand ways to
make a thousand dollars
and one of the ways in this book was
having
penny weighing machines
[Music]
and i sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine and how long
it would take for the profit for that
one to buy another one i would sit there
and
create these compound interest tables to
figure out how long it would take me to
have a weighing machine for every person
in the world
the first books i read on investment
were actually in my dad's office
[Music]
pretty soon i read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once
a few years ago i went to amazon and
sure enough they had this manual there
so
while reliving my youth other guys were
going to amazon probably and
and buying old playboys or something but
i bought old
movies manuals instead and when i got
out of school
i started selling stocks i was 20 years
old at the time and looked about 16 and
acted about 12 so i was not the most
impressive sales person anybody ever met
but what i would do was i i went through
page by page
looking for possibly undervalued stocks
leadership
at berkshire really consists
of taking a bunch of people who in a
baseball
uh uh analogy would be 400 hitters
and just handing them the bat and just
telling them to get up their plate and
take a big swing
there's very little to it beyond that
one thing i do
is i send him a letter the only thing i
tell him and this letter
which went out january 20th 2003 it says
it's been two and a half years since my
last memo
now how many big companies have do you
have the managers out there been two and
a half years since they've heard from
the home office
been two and a half years since my last
memo
here are a couple things to keep in mind
and
number one and this is number one every
time that this doesn't change it won't
change
two years from now or four years from
now or six years number one we can
afford to lose money
even a lot of money we cannot afford to
lose reputation
even a shredder reputation let's be sure
that everything we do in business can be
be reported on the front page of a
national newspaper
in an article written by an unfriendly
but intelligent reporter
in many areas including acquisitions
berkshire's results have benefited from
its reputation
and we don't want to do anything that in
any way can tarnish it
last year berkshire was ranked by
fortune as the fourth most admired
company in the world this year we were
third in the united states they just
published it
it took us 37 years to get there but we
could lose it in 37 minutes
and that's the message i mean we you
know we we can lose money it doesn't you
know
it's nicer to make money but we've got
we'll figure out ways to make money
but we can't lose we can't lose a
shredder reputation
because you don't get it back and you
can i said 37 minutes but you can lose
it a lot faster than that you can lose
it in five minutes
can you help us understand how to
cultivate how to cultivate that
mindset of being comfortable saying no
being comfortable delegating this is
something that
we found with our members is especially
difficult for young women
um and we'd love to just hear your take
on that and maybe any advice you have to
share about that i met bill
bill gates in 1991 and when i did it
we had a great time talking he thought
he was going to hate it and i
i wasn't too keen on it either and about
10 hours later we were still talking but
what really got him was when i pulled
out this little date book
i'm probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what the
oh no i have one over there
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's practically nothing
in it and bill was really impressed by
that
and uh you've got to keep control of
your time and
and you won't keep control of your time
unless you can say no
uh you you can't let other people
set your agenda in life and of course i
know i'm in a very fortunate position on
that because i
i i in another way i'm not so fortunate
because more people ask me things
and and and then they're usually friends
and they say well
can't you just make this one talk or
attend this one graduation or whatever
it may be
uh you know you've gotta you just have
to develop the ability to say no and
and and uh do it a few times uh i mean
you know the woman can't say no she's in
trouble right right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think it's a lot easier no it
it's there's a couple there's a few
things that really just aren't
uncomfortable enough i've
the thing i like the the thing i dislike
the most
the only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is that i have to
fire somebody
i mean that does not get easy for the
easier for me as life has gone on and
saying no is not
like firing people but it's got a little
bit of the same aspect to it
it's not easy to say no particularly to
a friend
uh but i will have every day three or
four or five requests to do something
and i
i can't do them all you know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier but
but just keep doing it right otherwise
other people will be running your life
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person
they increase their value at least 50
percent and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark
nothing happens you know basically and
and you have to be able to get
get both your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course
some people wish i'd taken a shorter
course now in terms of my talking later
on
but it it's just hugely important and
you if you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean
that doesn't mean that industries stay
good forever or businesses stay good
forever but
but learning to think about business
models what i learned
at 20 is useful to me now what i learned
at 25 is useful to me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes dramatically in terms of the
underlying principles it's like physics
i mean there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager
you know if he knows what makes a a good
product
uh and you learn that in one business
you can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and uh i don't think i can win every
game you know
somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chessy so
i don't play bobby fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time
and and learning what you're good at and
what you're not good at all of you in
this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it
you get your full potential or do you
get 100 horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room
if you did have a lack of education if
you didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life
it wouldn't make any difference what
that potential was because you'd never
unlock it
but the second most important thing and
equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we hire people we look for three
qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence
and we look for energy but if they don't
have the first one integrity
the other two will kill you because if
you're hiring somebody without integrity
you really want to be dumb and lazy
don't you i mean you know
the last thing in the world you want
form is to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing
[Music]
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump
or the color of your hair very easily
but you can
elect to have integrity that matches
anybody else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
[Music]
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part
go unused how would you advise people
who aren't necessarily going into a
career field in which you would make a
large base salary such as like
medicine or something like that maybe
performing arts or music how would you
advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well it is true that a market system
does not pay as well in some in some
activities as
as might seem appropriate for the
importance of those activities the
society
just take teaching for example i mean
teaching does not pay well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're the teachers
of your children are
as who your accountant is or you know
whatever or who's winning the
heavyweight title of the world or that
sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice uh whether
you're going to go into something
that for many people it'd be it'd be a
fundamental choice whether you're going
to go into something you love or
something
to try and make a lot of money i think
that generally it pays to go with what
you love
and i think that
it's very hard to find people when they
get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i i don't think
anybody's ever ever said that to me that
they wish they'd gone into something
else where they
were uncomfortable doing it or didn't
enjoy it didn't feel very productive but
made a lot of money
so i don't i don't think you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work
i would go to work in whatever turns you
on
it may turn out that it will be more
profitable than than you can think but
almost everybody here will make enough
money unless they get some terrible
habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is is uh is pretty darn good i
mean
it is it's not necessary to have
uh huge amounts of money in order to
enjoy yourself i enjoyed myself when i
was
had my ten thousand dollars and i live
in the same house that i lived in when i
was making it
when i had about that i bought it 41
years ago i like the house then i like
the house now
i mean if you think about it if you have
a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating a mcdonald's so we're we're to
push
on on food i mean you know in fact i
hope it's dairy queen actually in may
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order
we both can afford it um you know you'll
you'll wear the same clothes i wear i'll
pay more for my suits but as soon as i
put them on they look cheap on me so
we'll look about the same and uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and then and
what difference does it make if you have
50 more rooms or you know guest houses
or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the
about the greens keeper or something
when you get through so i
i i have been in the houses of people uh
where the houses are worth um
oh probably 200 times uh what my house
is worth and
i would not be any happier in those
houses at all in fact i'd be less happy
i just have one more thing
to worry about and you know the dozens
of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you probably drive a better
car i drive a car's about eight years
old i don't know what it's worth now but
it gets me around fine i mean i i'm
perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll work on the same computer pretty
much
the only difference will be how we
travel long distances
you know i will fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than than flying
southwest airlines or something and
which
i've got nothing against but that's the
one real big difference and
other than that i do what i like every
day i hope you you'll do what you like
every day to do and
i work with nice people i hope you work
with nice people uh
and that's there's 24 hours in the day
and those are where the hours go so
great wealth uh
is the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and and to trade
a decent income and something you love
doing
and something where you feel worthwhile
doing it for
huge wealth where you trade off a lot of
your principles
uh would be a terrible mistake over the
years i've developed a better
understanding of human nature
i can learn a lot about investments out
of a book but i don't think you can
learn as much about human beings you
really need some experiences and i'm
wiser in that respect than i was 40 or
50 years ago
even though i can't rattle off numbers
the same way i used to be able to
if you look around the world at the
people that
succeed and the people that other people
want to work with the natural leaders
it isn't because they have the highest
iq or they can kick a football the
furthest or anything like that
they're people that you want to work
with i mean i've got a wonderful friend
named tom murphy i know
i would do anything for him you know
he's never going to ask me to do it but
i mean i want it
but i want to do it i mean i want to do
it i mean he's done so many things for
me and then
and you know i you know you don't have
to pay me to do it or anything of the
sort that
that though that that's what you want to
you want to look for that and then you
want to be that
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so i it's
important to associate with people that
are
better than yourself and actually the
most important decision many of you make
not all of you will be the spouse you're
choosing
and you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse i can't
overemphasize how important that is and
you're right
the friends you have they will form you
as you go
through life and uh uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like i have an old-fashioned
belief that i can
only should expect to make money and
things that i understand and when i say
understand
i don't mean to understand you know what
the product does or anything like that
i mean understand what the economics of
the business
are likely to look at look like 10 years
from now or 20 years from now
i know in general what the economics of
say wrigley chewing gum will look like
10 years from now the internet isn't
going to change the way people chew gum
it isn't going to change which gum they
chew you know if you
own the chewing gum market in a big way
and you've got double mint and spearmint
and juicy fruit
those brands will be there 10 years from
now so i can't pinpoint exactly
what the numbers are going to look like
on wrigley but i'm not going to be way
off if i try to look forward on
something like that
that evaluating that company is within
what i call my circle of competence i
understand
what they do i understand the economics
of it i understand the competitive
aspects
of the business figuring out the
economic consequences
tv i think there's i don't know 20 25
million cents a year sold in the united
states
i don't think there's one of them made
in the united states anymore i mean
you'd say tv set manufacturer what a
wonderful business i
everybody and nobody had a tv in 1950
they're about 45 to 50. everybody has
multiple sets now
but nobody in the united states has made
any real money making the sense that
they're all out of business you know the
magna boxes the rca's all of those
companies
radio was the equivalent of the 20 over
500 companies making radios in the 1920s
again i don't think there's a
u.s radio manufacturer at the present
time but coca-cola
you know i was in 1884 jacob's pharmacy
or whatever and fellow
comes up with something a lot of copiers
over the years
but now you've got a company that is
selling
roughly 1.1 billion eight ounce servings
of its product not all cokes bright and
some others
daily throughout the world 117 years
later so understanding
the economic characteristics of a
business is different
than predicting the fact that an
industry is going to do wonderfully
so when i look at the internet
businesses or i look at tech messages i
say this is a marvelous thing and i love
to play around on the computer and
it now i order my books from amazon and
all kinds of things but i don't know
who's going to win
unless i know who's going to win i'm not
interested in investing i'll just play
around on the computer and uh
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing
it's not how important how large your
circle is
you don't have to be an expert on
everything but knowing where the
perimeter of that circle of what you
know and what you don't know is and
staying inside of it
is all important tom watson senior who
started ibm
said in his book he said i'm no genius
he said but i'm smart in spots and i
stay around those spots
and you know that is the key uh so if i
understand a few things
and i stick in that arena i'll do okay
and if i don't understand something but
i get all excited about it because my
neighbors are talking about stocks are
going up and everything
they start fooling around someplace else
eventually i'll get cream and i should
well in 1973
the washington post company had gone
public in 1971 right about the pentagon
papers type
time but in 73 uh the nixon
administration
uh was through bibi rebozo who was a
palo nixon's
they were challenging uh the licenses of
two of the florida television stations
the post owned so the stock went from
37 down to 16. now at 16 there were
about 5 million shares outstanding so
the whole washington post company was
selling for 80 million dollars
and that included the newspaper four big
tv stations newsweek you know and some
other assets and no debt to speak of
so the washington post company which was
intrinsically worth four or five hundred
million dollars
was selling for about 80 million in the
market we bought most of our stock at
about the equivalent of 100 million in
the market
and and it was it was ridiculous i mean
you had a business
that unquestionably was worth four or
five times what it was selling for and
nixon wasn't going to put them out of
business when you're doing these
analyses then
and now do you have computers that help
you or how did you actually
read all what do you guys get written
materials or how did you in those days
get the materials to read about the
washington post how do you do it today
well
same pretty much the same way except
there's fewer opportunities now but
i met bob woodward back and and and he'd
just
come out with all the president savannah
and all of a sudden as a
below 30 years of age he was getting
quite wealthy and we had we had
breakfast or lunch over at the madison
hotel and he said what do i do with this
money and i said i said investing is
just about assigning yourself the right
story i said imagine ben bradley this
morning said to you
what is the washington post company
worth what would you do if you have to
write the story in a month
you'd go out and interview tv brokers
and newspaper brokers and the owners and
you'd
try and value each asset i said that's
what i do i assign myself the right
story
and it's it's nothing more than that now
there's some stories i can't write if
you ask me to
write a story on you know what is some
glamorous
but non-profit making business worth i
don't know how to write that story but
if you ask me to write a story on what
is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go on
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse i can't
overemphasize how important that is and
you're right
the friends you have uh they will form
you as you go
through life and uh uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like
i was wondering if you have any stock
tips for any of the students you know
who are all trying to uh make make a
little living
i didn't think they taught that at
georgetown
they now the the best the best
investment i ever met well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor
i i don't remember what i paid but aside
from what i paid for my two marriage
licenses that was the best investment i
ever made
and uh it's very important
to have the right framework you need you
need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and
graham's approach is simple
but some people uh
adopt to it and and which i did
immediately and and most people don't
but if you have the right philosophy you
will find
opportunities uh as you go through the
next
20 30 40 50 years and and frankly you're
most likely to find them
uh when in periods like five years ago
when we were having
the panic i mean that uh
stocks sell at silly prices
from time to time most stocks at one
time or another sell at very silly
prices
and it doesn't take a high iq
to figure out that they're cheap but it
does take
a temperament that's willing to step up
and actually
act i tell people if they're going in
the investment business
if you've got 160 iq sell 30 points to
somebody else because you won't need it
i mean that
it yeah i mean i figured out very early
you don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate
but you do have to have the right
temperament and you have to be able to
ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide is this stock which is
selling it
x worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if
when you don't find them you don't do
anything so that's my
generalized stockton no name i was very
lucky in life
if you tell me who your heroes are i
will
make a pretty good prediction about how
what you're going to do and i i had the
right heroes i was very lucky in life
and my heroes never let me down and
started with my dad
and then i had others in business and so
i have had
great teachers some formal teachers some
that were just
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example
and if i hadn't had those
you know my life i'm sure would have
been very different there's a company
here in
in washington called geico you know and
i i first got exposed to that
in 1950 i was i was 20 years
i was 19 years old it was 51 i'm sorry i
was 20 years old and
i came down here and and i came down on
a saturday
because i learned that my professor who
i worshipped at columbia named ben
graham was the chairman
i got down here and the door was locked
when i went to the building because it
was saturday and i pounded on the door
and some janitor let me in and
a marvelous fellow named lauren davidson
uh spent four hours with me teaching me
all about insurance and he
he helped me so much in life but you're
going to get you're going to get help by
some wonderful people in life it's a
great thing to
to remember later on when you need to be
my age that you know all the help you've
received from different people because
uh nobody does it alone obama got in
trouble when he
said that in the campaign that you know
nobody does it by themselves nobody does
do it by themselves
we all sit in the shade of trees that
were planted by others so
it's obligatory i think to plant a few
trees ourselves if we've had good luck
uh
[Music]
it's it's been a great ride but it's not
over
what are the best ways for youth to get
started now in securing their financial
future for for what to secure their
financial future
for you youth oh well it's not it's not
very complicated uh
it goes back to getting full use out of
your own talents first
i mean the difference between whether
you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x
a year
uh 20 years from now uh
is going to be a function of how well
not how much talent you have but how
how well you use the talents you already
have and
so that is the your best financial
future
is your own ability and and and
your uh a capacity to
to use those abilities to their
potential
and they can't take that can't be taken
away from you
they can't even tax it i mean uh you
know most things
if if you wanna you know a piece of real
estate if they double the taxes they
double the taxes and that changes
your ownership in the property because
now in effect the taxing authorities own
more of it because they've got a greater
command on the revenue stream
uh the same thing about almost any asset
you have
but they they don't tax what's in your
head
and they don't tax your ability to start
performing when you
when you get to work in the morning and
finish in the evening
to to your potential one of the things
that amazes me
is how people who really do perform well
just sort of jump out
at you once you're running a business
when i got out of school i thought
you know everybody would behave that way
but they don't most people
sort of go go through life in a
sleepwalk
and and it if you don't
you will stand out so the big the
biggest thing for your financial future
is yourself
if success is contingent on a good plan
excellent
you know education and execution in a
driven mindset
what do you think makes businesses fall
apart
um when all of these factors have been
met
and con sorry go ahead some businesses
are just tough
i mean a significant percentage you know
the restaurants
that open up this year are going to fail
i mean there are a lot of a lot of tough
businesses
i've always said if you want to be
regarded as a great business person
find a great business and
uh there's a huge difference i mean it
does make a difference
i i use analogy when when i got out of
columbia one of my best friends was
a terrific talent and uh
he went to work in the steel business
and
he did okay but it was the wrong
business to be in
it's very important to get on the right
train i mean you want to you want to get
on a train
that's going to go 90 miles an hour and
not one that's going to go 30 miles an
hour and you're going to try to figure
out how to you know push it along a
little faster
so it really does make a huge difference
uh
and and there are some businesses
that are inherently uh there's far more
opportunity and than others so
you want to give a lot of thought to
what train you're getting on and
uh i owned a half interest when i was i
don't know
21 or 22 in a service station uh a
sinclair service station with a
pal of mine in the national guard it was
a lousy business you know we had a guy
right next to us he kept selling more
gallons of gas that we did he would cut
our prices and everything
i mean i i don't i don't care if you
know if you're a combination of steve
jobs and
larry ellison and everybody else you're
not going to succeed if you've got a guy
selling
gas below costs next year so you know
it's important to get on the right train
to go back to when i started my
partnership in 1956
that berkshire came out of there were
seven people sitting there at a table
uh having dinner
relatives primarily and i said here's
the partnership agreement
it's done under nebraska law it's four
or five pages you don't need to read it
but i said here's a little half page
what i call the ground rules and i want
you to read these
and if you feel okay about that about
the interaction what the expectations
are and all of that sort of thing
then we'll join forces and if you don't
it's fine
other people have you know but we don't
we shouldn't be partners i mean
you know if i'm gonna have a partnership
with somebody i want to be compatible it
is
you know and when you have a
public company you can't control who
comes in i can't control some guy that
comes in and thinks we're gonna pay big
dividends or split the stock or
something like that
so by my actions and my communications
and everything
i want to attract the people that
from the public market that i want and i
want to keep the others away
costco was built saul price who started
the price
club that thing he sat down and figured
out the customer he didn't want
and he set up a system that would keep
away the customer he didn't
want who did not want he didn't want
somebody buying a quart of milk
with somebody behind them with a with a
basket of 200
worth of goods waiting for that so we
put in a membership fee and by putting
in a membership page
he killed all the drop in business the
business to belong to the 7-eleven
we want berkshire to to keep out people
who have expectations
about us that are different than ours i
mean good for them and i hope they find
somebody they said
but if you're going to run a church
you want you want your seats to be
filled by people that are generally
want to listen to your form of religion
then and you don't want it to change
every week and say gee i need a new
group and i'll go out and talk to a
bunch of investors and get them to come
to my church this sunday
because there's only so many seats in
the church there's a million 645 000 or
so
a equivalent shares and those are the
seats and i want them occupied by people
that are on the same page i am well i
was lucky that i got
started early i mean always helps if you
get started early and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down
his office on saturdays and so at age
probably seven or something i started
reading these books that were around the
place and
so i had a 15-year jump on many people
in
a sense and that that helped a lot and
and i was always fascinated by them i
knew what i wanted to do early and i
think that's a
that's a huge advantage too and then
you don't need you don't need a lot of
brains in this business i mean i've
always said if you've got an iq of 160
give away 30 points to somebody else
because you don't need an investment
what you do need
is emotional stability you have to you
have to be able to think independently
and you have to be
you have to be when you come to a
conclusion you have to really not care
what other people say and
and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's
that's tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that when the market's good
if you feel good don't if you feel bad
you should probably do it
right but uh how uh how how did you uh
what was that extra thing where uh so
many will acknowledge that
and yet we saw in the current crisis
they they panic while you went into
seemingly potential disasters like ge
and goldman sachs
i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just
it never bothered me if people disagreed
with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know a thing about
i just stay away from those so i stay
within what i call my circle of
competence you know
that tom watson said it best he said you
know he said he said i'm no genius but
i'm smart in spots and i stay around
those spots well
i try and stay around those spots and i
i just don't have a
problem if if if somebody says you know
you're wrong on something i just i
go back and look at the facts and and
i think that i think that really is much
more important frankly than than having
a few points of iq
or or having an extra course or two in
in school or anything of the sort you
need emotional stability
70 years ago i was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when i was in high school i really
only had two things on my mind
girls and cars and
it wasn't doing very well with girls so
we'll talk about cars
but let's just imagine that when we
finish
i'm gonna let each one of you pick out
the car of your choice sounds good
doesn't it
uh pick it out any color
you name it it'll be tied up with a bow
and it'll be at your house tomorrow
and you say well what's the catch
and the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime
now what are you going to do knowing
that that's the only car
you're ever going to have and you love
that car you're going to take care of it
like you cannot believe now what i'd
like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime
but you're going to get one body and one
mind
and that's all you're going to get and
that body and mind
feels terrific now but it has to last
you a lifetime
two women uh that
each sold the business to berkshire
hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world
and one of them was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english had a
tag around her neck
the tag said
fort dodge iowa the red cross
daughter of fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had
come to the country a couple of years
earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy she couldn't pick
up the language she couldn't learn a
word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha so they came to omaha
in 1919 and
there she found a small colony of
russian jews so she started feeling more
at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school
that day and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father fifty dollars at a
time
she sold used clothing to do it she had
four children
during this period and by 1937
after 20 years she saved twenty five
hundred dollars
she went to chicago and she bought
what she could have furniture her dream
had always been to open
a furniture store and this woman without
who had never gone to school one day in
her life
with 2 500 but with the same spirit that
the people in this room had
about having a dream and working to
accomplish that dream she built a
business
which she sold to me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin lived
while she she worked for me until she
was 103.
and then i'm not saying then she retired
and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all of berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b with her twenty five hundred
dollars
one further fact about her she could not
read or write and she went into a
furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she
brought a determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this
incredible business you've all got the
qualities it takes three qualities
essentially to do well and extremely
well actually in this country
it takes intelligence it takes energy
and it takes integrity and i say if you
don't have integrity
you know if we don't want to hire
somebody that's got intelligence and
energy if they don't have integrity we'd
rather hire somebody that's
dumb and lazy if they don't have
integrity because they probably will
never get around it because they're
doing something
and integrity is absolutely an option
you know
you may not be able to throw a football
60 yards and you know you may not be
able to run the hundred and in in nine
eight you know you may not be able to
sink three pointers from but
you can choose where you stand on the
integrity scale
yeah you can't you weren't born wired
one way or the other that is an absolute
choice you make
i got an awful lot of good advice from
my dad and
he didn't he didn't lay it on me i mean
he just you know
you you you picked it up from him but
there was never any of this you know do
this do that uh
type of thing at all but but i think he
really
taught me that it's more important uh in
terms of what's on your inner score card
than your outer score card i mean some
people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what
what the world's going to think of this
or that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're gonna gonna have a
pretty happy life and i think the people
that strive too much for the outer
scorecard uh sometimes find it it's a
little hollow when they get all through
i should mention one thing about reading
uh
it was at the library here at colombia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than
any other uh student i lived there
practically
but you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
because of that librarian directing me
to some
other book and then following through on
that it's
the chance i i i read about one-fifth
the pace
the bill does but i still spend five or
six hours a day reading i mean it's just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people that have been excited and
seeing so extraordinary the lessons and
the you know the discouragements they
face just everything about it so i did
you can't get enough of reading i was
wondering how do you decide
what you invest your time and money in
yeah well i
i i like to find
businesses that have good economics now
what what are good economics well good
economics are a business that has
some kind of a moat around it that
makes its product or its service or its
location or something
a little more desirable than to the
customer than any other sort of
comparable product
uh you know the number one candy bar in
the last 30 or 40 years has been
snickers
people don't fool around with different
candy bars they fool around with
different
length dresses they fool around you know
with all kinds of things but they don't
fool around with candy bars
because they figure you know they're
going to go in and lay out 50 cents or
whatever it is and put it in their mouth
and they're not going to for 50 cents
and putting in your mouth i mean you're
not going to say i'll
i'll put in i'll lay out 45 cents and
put something else in my mouth so
you find that very stable and we like
businesses
that we think we can figure out where
they're going to be in 10 or 15 years
i don't know where the information
technology businesses are going to be in
10 or 15 years i know where snickers
bars are going to be in 10 or 15 years
they're going to be selling just about
this you know the way they do now i know
where wrigley's gum is going to be in 10
or 15 years
there's not going to be a lot of
innovation in in in chewing them
uh and people the internet's not going
to cause people to quit chewing gum
either i mean at least
i mean gates may think so but i don't
think so but uh
[Music]
it's it's predictability
regarding the sustainability of a
competitive advantage some something
special about a product
having the right heroes you know is
terribly important
you know you tell me who a
ten-year-old's heroes are and i can give
you a pretty good prediction about
about how they're going to turn out you
want to choose your heroes very
carefully
uh because you're going to you're going
to look like them at some point
and you're lucky if you've got if you've
got the right ones
what do you consider the most important
quality
for an investment manager it's a
temperamental quality not an
intellectual quality
you don't need tons of iq in this
business i mean you have to have enough
iq to get from here to downtown omaha
but
but you do not have to be able to play
three-dimensional chess
or be in the top leagues in terms of
bridge playing or something of the sort
you need a stable
personality you need a temperament that
neither derives great pleasure from
being with the crowd or against the
crowd
because this is not a business where you
take polls it's a business where you
think
and ben graham would say that you're not
right or wrong
because a thousand people agree with you
and you're not right or wrong because a
thousand people disagree with you you're
right because your facts and your
reasoning are right
shortly after i met bill gates bill's
dad asked each of us to write down on a
piece of paper one word that would best
describe
what it helped us the most bill and i
without any collaboration at all these
wrote the word focus
well focus has always been a strong part
of my
personality if i get interested in
something i get really interested
if i get interested in new subject i
want to read about it i want to talk
about it and i want to meet people that
are involved in it
economic predictions just don't enter
into our decisions charlie mugger my
partner i
in you know 54 years now we've never
made a decision
based on an economic prediction we make
business predictions about what
individual businesses will do
over time and we compare that to
what we have to pay for but we have
never said yes
to something because we thought the
economy was going to do well in the next
year or two years and we've never said
no to anything
because we were right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right
how would you define true success
well i've i've said many times that that
if you get to be 65 or 70
and later and and the people that you
want to have love you actually do love
you
you're a success i've never seen anybody
that
reaches that age i mean i'm not talking
about somebody that's in extreme poverty
or pain or something but i've never seen
anybody that
if they have a lot of people that love
them that
is other than happy and i've seen some
very very wealthy people that
they give testimonial dinners too and
name schools hamster and everything
nobody nobody loves them i always look
at iq and
and talent as sort of representing the
the horsepower of the motor but then in
terms of the output
the efficiency which which the motor
works that depends on rationality
because a lot of people start out with
400 horsepower motors and
get 100 horsepower of output and it's
way better to have a 200 horsepower
motor and get it all into output and
so why do why do smart people do things
that interfere with
really getting the the output they're
entitled to and it's uh
it gets into the habits and the
character into temperament and
it really gets into behaving in a
rational manner and not letting not
getting in your own way
as i say everybody here has the ability
absolutely to do anything i do and much
beyond
and and some of you will and some of you
won't but it it
it will the ones that won't it will
because me because
uh uh you're getting your own way it
won't because the the world doesn't
allow you to it will be because you
don't uh allow yourself to
you're lucky in life if you can find
your passion i tell the students you
know
you may have to take a job or two you
know you got to eat
but never give up searching for the job
that's your passion
try to find the job that you would have
if you were independently rich
that's the job i have and when you find
that job the job that causes you
to be excited every day and forget about
the pain
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that
my partner charlie is 89 and we were
talking about that this weekend you know
i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside
right i love to ride around at a private
point i will
totally acknowledge that leaving that
out you know i'm basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i live and easily
live on a hundred thousand dollars a
year
and then it and i wouldn't live i
wouldn't have better
if i had eight houses if i hadn't you
know a 400-foot yacht or anything of the
sword
i've been on 400-foot yachts so i've
been a lot of fancy houses
but i'm in a house that i bought 55
years ago
it's warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer
it has everything i wanted plus it has
all kinds of good memories
like my kids have good thoughts about it
i can't imagine
living any better i paid thirty one
thousand five hundred dollars for it i
could pay 31 million
for a house and and it wouldn't it
wouldn't do for me what this present
house does
the most important thing uh
aside from the things i've talked about
already is is really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are
i mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents uh
they're gonna have enormous influence on
you but you don't get a choice on that
but you get choices as you go down the
line and you
who you who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important for most people in terms of
that decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business with the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's
better than you are and then he or she
and hopefully you hope they don't figure
it out too fast
when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got i can
guarantee you that you'll all do fine on
money anyway i mean
uh you know think about it seven hours a
day
you know you're in a bed you've got
exactly the same mattress i've got if
you don't listen
to it the furniture mark you know i mean
so so that when we're on a parody i
can't i can't outdo you you know in
terms of my sleeping enjoyment you can
you can match it by by buying this
mattress which we'll give you a special
price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat up dolls and burger king
and and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car up till about a year ago
you know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me and they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it
you know we dress more or less the same
i mean i pay more for my clothes but
they look cheap when i put them on so
we're really we're on a parody yeah so
so the money isn't going to be that big
a deal everybody in this country is
going to you know that
with the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean
you know so i won't i don't want i'm not
short changing it i'm just saying you
can't do
too much about that but you will measure
your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want at 70
or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end
i mean you can't you know you
you can't buy love i mean it doesn't
work you buy sex you can buy testimonial
dinners you can buy your name on
buildings you can do all kinds of things
but the you know the only way you get to
be you know love is to be lovable
it's kind of irritating actually got a
lot of money be more fun to just write
out a check for a million dollars
since everybody you know from now on
loves me but it doesn't work that way
and in fact it the only way is to be is
to be lovable and you know i've got this
friend
who uh who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and what is it now it's uh
60 years later you know she's still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself in
determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in her mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70 if you've got
a lot of people that would hide you
you've had a successful life i know
people who have a tremendous amount of
money
no one would hide their own kids
wouldn't hide them i mean
they they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to
it you know they they don't have
anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and uh
my friend tom murphy at camp cities tv i
mean
dozens of people would hide murph you
know all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know that uh
ben graham a lot of people would have my
my dad it would have had a number
and then like i say that i can i can
tell you people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and
the kids may put up with them and hope
they don't change their will or
something but
the truth is that nobody would hide them
and if you've got a lot of people that
would hide you
when you get to be 70 70.
you will have a very successful life i'm
72. i'm getting social security now so
i'm you know i
i should be in florida you know pushing
shuffleboard around or something of the
sort but
but but i do what i can do anything in
the world i want to do but what i want
to do is run berkshire hathaway now why
do i want to run it that way
a i get to paint my own painting you
know i go down there every day
and i feel like you know i feel like
michelangelo there you know working on
the sistine chapel or something
nobody else may think it's a great
painting but i get to paint my own
painting
i do not have people second guessing me
i do not have
people saying why don't you use a little
more red paint than blue paint why don't
you paint a seascape instead of a
landscape
i get to do my own thing i get the it's
it's
it's a form of creativity it's it's
exactly like
somebody feels it's a professional
golfer or somebody feels it's a painter
they're not doing it for the money
primarily uh
they're doing it because they like doing
something we've got a company flight
safety with
trains more pilots than anybody in the
world flight safety
is run by an 85 year old man al ulshi
al started the company with ten thousand
dollars in 1951
it now trains four or five times as many
pilots as a
non-military pilot as any as anybody in
the world
and he is there at 85 and it's a matter
of public record he's got a billion
dollars worth of berkshire shares
he works seven days a week he loves it
and he loves it for the same reason that
i love what i do
he gets to do it his way he buys these
big simulators that you train pilots in
he doesn't have to check with me as to
whether to spend 15 million dollars for
a simulator
he doesn't ask me he knows so much more
about it than you know that i do
why in the world would he ask me well i
can't tell what kind of a plane i'm in
you know when i'm flying around
and al is spending a couple hundred
million dollars a year on
simulators spending berkshire hathaway
money
and he never checks with alma he's never
had to come to omaha
uh for any kind of meetings he runs his
own business
and that's what he loves in life and i
let him do it i mean that's my
contribution to it is is
really turning loose his energies and
you know they were properly directed
before we bought the company seven or
eight years ago why do why should i
think that you know he couldn't keep
running it after that and like i say at
85 he's still running it and that
feeling
of ownership is really extraordinary and
it's so much better i mean it's the way
i like to work
uh and it's the way you know it's the
way susan jack likes to work it's the
way
al yoshi likes to work and i don't need
to be
in washington to figure out what the
washington post uh
newspaper is worth and i don't need to
be in new york to figure out what
some other company is worth it's it's
it's simply it's an intellectual process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are
what is the intellectual process
intellectual processes
is defining your level defining your
area of competence and valuing
businesses
and then within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value
and there are all kinds of things i'm
not competent to value but there are a
few that i am competent to value
have you ever bought a technology
company no i really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them
so you haven't ever owned for example
ibm never owned ibm
company i'm a sensational company but i
haven't owned ibm
and so here is this technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right
past me is that all right with you it's
okay with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about and
that may be too bad but you know why
should i know all about them i haven't
worked that hard on them
in securities business you literally
every day have thousands of the major
american corporations offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily and you don't have to make any
decisions you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you got a
strike call on you if you get too many
coal i know you're out
in the securities business you sit there
and they throw
u.s steel at 25 and they throw general
motors at 68 and you don't have to swing
at any of them
they may be wonderful pitches to swing
at but if you don't know enough you
don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally you get
one
right there where you want it something
that you understand and then you swing
and
so you might not swing for six months
you might not swing for two years
but i do tell them those students you
know
that if i gave you a car and it'd be the
only car you're getting the rest of your
life
you take care of it like you can't
believe any scratch you'd fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage and do all these things
and
you get exactly one mind of one and one
body in this world
and and you can't start taking care of
it when you're 50 by that time you'll
rush it out if you haven't done anything
so you you should
just really make sure that you just
remember that you just got one
mind and body to get through life with
and to do the most with it one of the
things you do
in your annual report which has become a
classic
is you will discuss what went wrong like
dexter
and what you and how and and and what
you learned from it
tough tough to do well it's it's it's
very important to recognize mistake i
mean
if somebody goes around and says you
know i never made a mistake i mean you
quit listening to them i mean
you know they're in the dream world so
so
facing up to it uh it's it's a little
like in
in in terms of discussing issues you
should be able to discuss the other
fellows position
just as well as you can discuss your own
so i mean that's part of thinking well
and
and certainly part of making good
decisions in business
is recognizing the poor decisions you've
made and and
why they were poor and and and that
doesn't mean you never do the same thing
i mean it
because sometimes it was a freak
situation but
but i have made lots of mistakes i'm
going to make more mistakes
uh but you know babe ruth struck out a
lot of times i mean
it's the name of the game that you do it
you don't want to expect perfection in
yourself
you want to strive to do your best but
but it's too demanding to expect
perfection in yourself and it does some
good to recognize them and not start
trying to go around kidding people about
them what other habits did you cultivate
in your 20s and your 30s that you now
see as being foundational to your
success as a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i
i i really read a lot and i aspired to
learn everything that i could about the
subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i said to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you
or you could be given 10 of the future
earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or can run the fastest or
anything like that that's the right
height
hair color you're gonna you're gonna
pick the person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and
when you look at all of the qualities
that you admire in other people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
molester like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the extreme you pick the
person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you get rid of those and it's a
pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
as a general matter as a one piece of
specific finance
financial advice i would say
you know avoid credit cards just forget
about them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20
over time you know if you can find
anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying 18 or 20 percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so
the trick i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there
you know and uh and that's true in
financial matters as well you want to
figure out where you don't want to be
uh ahead of time and avoid that and i
get about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and really only society
can solve that one
uh uh in terms of protecting people
against that
that's just plain bad luck but the other
one is from people who run up
credit card debt and they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better it's way easier to stay
out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and i will guarantee you if you run
a big credit card that
you will be in trouble uh probably the
rest of your life
in terms of uh your financial situation
on the other hand if you get ahead of
the game
uh even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're you people owe you
money or
equities owe you ownership uh you'll be
way out of the game
compared to paying it uh being always
being paying
your creditors every month so my advice
to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it i
have constructed
a business that fits me
it's kind of crazy to spend your life
painting if you're painting a subject
you don't want to look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business on an unlimited canvas in a way
[Music]
it's a different sort of place
i work with great group of people that
make my life very easy
and take good care of me
we have 25 people in the office and
if you go back it's the exact same 25
the exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire we don't have a public
relations department we don't investor
relations we don't have a general
counsel
we don't have a human relations
department we just don't go for anything
that
people do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life i like and
it's not work to me it's just a form of
play basically
if somebody told me 10 years ago what
was going to happen the next 10 years we
could have made a lot of money in the
bond market together you know but
but it's there's always a reason
afterwards
tomorrow's paper will say stocks went
down today because of you know but they
didn't they didn't write it this
morning's paper that stocks are going to
go down to today
you have to know what you don't know and
you have to make sure
that what you don't know isn't all
important i mean you know if there's
four boxes there
you want to get to what is knowable
and and and and and and which
uh is favorable and there's
things that you'll miss out on because
they belong in
other three boxes one of which will be
favorable
another one the favorable and uh the
fact that you're missing out on 90
of the stuff doesn't really make any
difference if the 10
you do is right in my own case i was
sort of wired for capital allocation and
being wired for capital allocation a
couple hundred years ago
in nebraska wouldn't have been a thing
uh and
and even now being born in various parts
of the world it wouldn't have been much
but here i was in this
soon-to-be very rich capitalistic system
and and
it just so happened that what i did paid
off enormously in a market system like
we have and i
if i'd had a talent in some other area
that was
way less commercial i mean i would have
i would have had a good time doing it
but it wouldn't have paid off like this
but of course jay said it perfectly when
he talked about
you know he's in the recording for
himself and the money comes afterwards i
mean i
i got to do what i love i mean and it
doesn't get any luckier than that if
if you can spend your lifetime and i'm
80 now and doing things you love every
single day i mean
i would be doing what i did and what i
do now and i would have done in the past
if the payoff had been in seashells or
sharks teeth or anything else
that if you can go to work every morning
i tap dance to work you know when i come
down and i
every day's exciting i like to sit and
think and i spend a lot of time doing
that
and sometimes it's pretty unproductive
but but
i i find it enjoyable to think about
particularly about about business or
investment problems they're easy it's
the human problems that are the tough
ones
sometimes there aren't any good answers
with human problems there's almost
always a good answer with money
i've got this rule you know the first
rule is don't lose in the second rule is
ever forget the first rule so
it really isn't so much having a lot of
brilliant decisions
it's just not really having some
terrible ones and and
and frankly i did learn from ben graham
how to avoid ever having any disasters
and investments uh
it wasn't that you were going to come up
with the very smartest thing but if you
never have any
any significant losses you know some
singles and doubles will produce a lot
of runs before you get through
i advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleep walk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not
it it's not a good idea yeah
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain
guess what i'm talking about
you really want to be doing what you
love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it let's
do it here
now the end is near
and so i face the final curtain
my friends i'll say it clear
i'll
[Music]
much more than this i did it
my way both of us know
that we've done better by having ethics
warren's not interested in making money
by cheating people
warren's opinions of wall street
investment bankers
would not endear him to their mothers
he feels that they're for the most part
not out for their clients
they're out for their own business
interests
in the late 1960s there were just a
flood of
accounting shenanigans and mergers built
upon
false accounting and misleading people
it was a time when
a lot of charlatans were prevailing in
wall street and were being
applauded by wall street and i
understood what the game was about but i
didn't want to play in it so
i closed down the partnership at the end
of 1969
and i took on the title of chairman for
the berkshire hathaway
questions about the personal quality we
look for in the and the executives we
place at our various companies
the first thing is we don't usually
place them i mean they come with them uh
we don't have anybody to place so i have
the problem occasionally if somebody
dies or
uh to replace a ceo
but most of our ceos came with the deal
clayton holmes which we're buying comes
with kevin clayton right
running it we will put no one in there
he will run the place just as before
but in terms of the personal quality
when when a
seller comes to me with a business
whether it's clayton or any of those
and the others ike friedman at borsheims
mrs b
at nebraska for nature mark when they
come to me the first question i have to
ask myself because i'm counting on them
to run the place
i have to decide what do they love the
money or do they love the business
now there's nothing wrong with liking
the money i mean they all like money but
but they've got to love the business
they got to have a passion for it
because if i give them a whole bunch of
money and they love the money and they
don't love the business
no matter what they tell me six months
from now they'll be gone you know i mean
they'll just all of a sudden say why am
i getting up at seven in the morning
just so i can send a lot of money to
omaha you know i mean it
it just it won't work so they have to
love the business i mean i want people
with a
passion for the business i used to say
that i had a one-line
employment form one question employment
form the question was
are you a fanatic you know if you
answered yes you got the job because i
want somebody's
fanatic about their business you have
over a hundred billion dollars of cash
um
berkshire does that work
berkshire has over 100 billion in cash
and you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress
so how much cash should an ordinary
investor have
on a percentage basis do you think it
depends on our personal situation
if if if you're working in
something where you're living off your
your
your paycheck from week to week you want
to have a little cash around and and you
certainly don't want to have a
credit card that's maxed out or anything
like that uh
but if you know if if your house is paid
off
if you don't have big living expenses
you got a portfolio of
of decent diversified businesses
uh you really need any cash the
allowance when i was a little boy it was
a nickel a week
but i like the idea of having a little
more than a nickel a week
to work with and i went into business
very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold
saturday in post liberty magazine ladies
home journal you name it
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss that's one
thing i like about delivering papers
[Music]
i can arrange the route i wanted nobody
was bothering me at five or six in the
morning
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny shirt into something else
people ask me what they should take in
business school and and
and uh or even if they don't go to
business school what they need to know
before getting in business and i tell
them you know you have to
you have to understand accounting it's
the language i mean it would be
it's like being in a foreign country
without knowing the language if you're
in business and you don't understand
accounting so it it you want to get as
comfortable with that
uh as you are with the english language
it
it's made me uh a lot of money because i
i listened to what ray dean had to say
53 or 4 years ago
and have been able to understand uh
what i was seeing on pieces of paper
what that told me about businesses
and the limitations of what it told me
about business henry ford as you may
know
failed twice before he started the ford
motor company in 1903 i mean
the the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you
keep learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers
what you can bring especially to the
party and to do that
you need a genuine
a genuine desired day in day out
to delight the customer
i've never i've never seen a business
and i've seen a lot of businesses but
i've never seen one that
delights the customer that that doesn't
succeed i mean what you want is that
customer the next day
when they think do i want to rent a car
or do i want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind you know
it's the place where they've had a great
experience
um i don't know what i paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech i will
say i i have no idea but what i or the
shirt i'm wearing others
but i do know i will remember
how i was treated when i bought it i
mean
you long forget about the price
but you never forget whether you had a
good experience
or a poor experience uh with
the purchase experience somebody once
said that the
chains of habit are too light to be felt
until they're too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw up and i knew
if i didn't cure it then
i'd never cured it and so i
saw an ad in the paper for the dale
carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail
on a property they made us all these
crazy things to get out of ourselves and
so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Applause]
[Music]
if i hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree i got from the university of
nebraska
you'll not see the master's degree i got
from columbia university
but you'll see the little award
certificate i got from the dale carnegie
course if you look around you at the
people you admire
you know they have certain qualities i
mean you've got you've got friends why
do you like them you know
generally you know that they generally
they have an upbeat
attitude on life generally they're
generous people they're humorous people
they're people that do more than their
share
they're people that are thinking about
something nice they can do for you
and all of those qualities attract you
and none of those are
are innate at birth i mean you you can
acquire those and then there's other
people that turn you off
you know and and uh they have habits
they take credit for things they didn't
do
they don't show up on time whatever it
may be they're a little dishonest about
things
and if you're looking at your life at
a young age like you are and you can
choose what kind of a person you can be
why not be the person you admire rather
than the person you can't stand it's so
simple
so just write down the qualities you
like
take take your five best friends why do
you like them and just write down those
qualities
and you will find there's no quality
there that you can you can't have
yourself
and similarly with the five people you
can't stand to be around
but those put those things down to turn
you off about those people
and if they turn you off about them why
should you possess them you're gonna
it's so simple uh you know
it's it's not it's not it's not like
some something complicated that you
think you should be learning you know
whether it's
investing in the stock market no but
it's it's enormously important to have
people work with you in life
right they're going to work with you in
life if they like you you know and they
may occasionally i mean if you're in the
army or something
you know you may work for somebody that
you don't like but by and large
you're going to get the best out of
people if they feel good about you
and it's just so easy but you've got to
develop the habits early because
you can't say i'm going to suddenly
become a terribly attractive person when
i'm 60.
it just doesn't work that way so pick up
the right habits now
and i will guarantee you if you
actually just write down those qualities
and think about it
you will find you can have every one of
the attractive qualities get rid of the
ones that are
are negative and your life will be
different well i mean i've made a lot of
mistakes biggest mistake
well not the biggest necessarily the
biggest but but buying berkshire
hathaway itself was a mistake
because berkshire was a lousy textile
business and i brought it very cheap
i'd been taught by ben graham to buy
things
on a quantitative basis look around for
things that are cheap
and that i was taught that we'll say in
1949 or
they made a big impression on me so i
went around looking for what
i call you cigar butts of stocks
and the cigar butt approach to buying
stocks is that you walk down the street
and you're looking around for cigarette
butts and you find this honestly this
terrible looking soggy
ugly looking cigar one puff left in it
but you pick it up and you get your one
puff disgusting you throw it away but
it's free
i mean it's cheap and then you look
around for another soggy you know
one puff cigarette well that's what i
did for years
it's a mistake uh although you make
money doing it but you can't make it
with big money it's so much easier just
to buy wonderful businesses so now i
would rather buy a wonderful business at
a fair price
than a fair business at a wonderful
price but in those days i was buying
cheap stocks and berkshire was selling
below it's working capital for sure you
got the plants for nothing you got the
machinery for nothing
you got the inventory and receivables at
the discount it was cheap
so i bought it and 20 years later i was
still running a
lousy business and that money did not
compound
you really want to be in a wonderful
business because the time is the friend
of the wonderful business you keep
compounding it keeps doing more
business and you keep making more money
time is the enemy
of the lousy business i could have sold
berkshire perhaps liquidated it
and made a quick little profit you know
one puff
but staying with those kind of
businesses is is a big mistake
so you might say i learned something out
of
that mistake and i would have been way
better off taking
what i did with berkshire is i kept
buying better businesses i started
insurance business sees candy the
buffalo
all kinds of things i would have been
way better doing that with a
with a brand new little entity that i'd
set up
rather than using berkshire as the
platform now i've had a lot of fun out
of it
i mean everything in life seems to turn
out for the better so i i don't have any
complaints about that
but it was a dumb thing to do i went in
the u.s
air i bought a preferred stock in 1989.
uh as soon as my check cleared
the company went into the red never got
out i mean it was a really dumb
i mean i've got an 800 number i call now
whenever i think about buying an
airline stock i call them up any hour
that fortunately i can call them at
three in the morning and i just dial and
i say my name's warren i'm an aeroholic
you know i'm thinking about buying this
thing and they talk me down i mean
it takes takes hours sometimes but it's
worth it believe me
uh if you ever think about that airline
buying an airline just call me and i'll
give you the 800 number because
you don't want to do it but
we got lucky in terms of how we
eventually came out on it
but it was a dumb dumb decision
all mine ted williams wrote a book
called the science of hitting and ended
he had a
picture of himself at bat and the strike
zone broken into
i think 77 squares and he said if he
waited for the pitch that was really in
his sweet spot
he would bat 400 and if he had to swing
at something on the lower
corner he would probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in
i can look at a thousand different
companies and i don't have to be right
on
every one of them or even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing is just to
sit there and watch pitch after pitch go
by
and wait for the one right in your sweet
spot and if people are yelling swing you
bum
ignore them there's a temptation
for people to act far too frequently in
stock simply
because they're so liquid over the years
you develop a lot of filters and i do
know
what i call my circle of compounds so i
i stay within that circle
and i don't worry about things that are
outside that circle
defining what your game is where you're
going to have an edge
is enormously important i was wondering
how you define success personally
well i i can certainly define happiness
because that's what that's what i am
i mean i i and if that
i mean i get to do what i like to do
every single day of the year
and i get to do it with people i like i
get the
i get i don't have to associate with
anybody causes my stomach to churn
and uh the only thing in my job i don't
like and this only happens about every
three or four years
occasionally i have to fire somebody and
i don't like that's the only thing
other than i tap dance to work and i get
down there and i think i'm supposed to
lie on my back and paint the ceiling you
know or something like microwaves i mean
that's the way i feel and and it it it
doesn't diminish
it it's it's tremendous fun so uh
you know if uh they say that uh
success is uh uh uh getting what you
want and happiness is wanting what you
get
well i don't know which one applies in
this case but i
i do know that i i wouldn't be doing
anything else i mean
i do advise you you know when you go out
to work go to work for an organization
that you admire
people you admire because it'll it'll
it'll turn you on and and
uh you ought to be happy where you are
working and
i always worry about people who say you
know i'm going to do this for 10 years i
really don't like it very well then i'll
do 10 more years of this
i mean that's a little like saving up
sex for your old age i mean
not a very good idea
so get right in you can't recommend that
get ready
get right into what you enjoy you know
and and
and you'll be successful at it you
really will i mean you won't be able to
miss
and uh you know that's uh
uh i don't regard what i do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me i mean i happen to be
wired in a certain way that what i do
works in this if i had to do what
you know bill does i mean it lasts about
10 minutes
and that's true of a lot of things but i
luckily i kind of stumbled into the
thing that i
i do best and and that you know that
it's worked out well
how do you turn failure into a plus and
it's true when i was at the university
of nebraska
one day i was reading the daily
nebraskan and it said
in room 300 or something
at three o'clock there will be this
panel of three
professors here at the university and
they're going to award the nathan gold
scholarship i don't know whether you
still you still have that around
and at the time uh it said it would give
you
500 to go to the graduate school of your
choice i don't know whether it's
changed an amount but but that that was
it so i read this
and i went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was
and i walked in the room and there were
the professors
and i was the only student that showed
up i mean it really got to them i mean
they they were stuck they you know they
kept waiting and looking at their watch
and hoping there would be more
candidates
but there no one came in so i won 500
by by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here i was i had 500 to go
toward any it wasn't it wasn't the limit
is any any graduate school
for a master's degree so i applied to
harvard my dad wanted me to
and uh i shortly heard from harvard
and they said go to chicago and meet
this fellow running
that who interviews applicants from the
midwest
so i got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and i
spent about 10 hours on the burlington
going to chicago
then i transferred to another little
interurban train to go up to this
country day school where this fellow was
the headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for harvard
and i got there and after about 10
minutes he
he said better think about something
else that
you know he uh come back later on i was
i was 19 at the time and
uh i looked about 12 you know and and i
and i acted about eight so it was not a
great combination uh
but so he he said forget it so i spent
i took the little interurban train back
to chicago and i took the 10-hour train
back to oman all the time
you know what do i tell my parents you
know it's kind of embarrassing
but it was it was the luckiest thing
ever happened to me
i because
if i'd gone to harvard i would have gone
to a two-year business school
i i instead applied to columbia where i
could graduate in one year and get a
master's degree
luckily that by the accident of it and
being in the nebraska national guard
which did not get called up for the
korean war
i missed going in the korean war
i
i got to meet ben graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and i probably got my wife that way
because she was going to northwestern
and i was able to put on sort of a full
court press because i got out in one
year
and otherwise uh she'd she'd have met
some other guy i mean i i got her before
the competition showed up and
uh so it worked out wonderfully it
couldn't have worked out better
and that's been that's been my life
basically i mean it the
things you know you will get some
disappointments you know
uh but the future is what counts
that'd be fun if i knew every decision i
was
going to make was going to be perfect it
would not be as much fun be like playing
golf and knowing you're going to hit
a hole in one on every hole you wouldn't
play golf
if every time you got on a tee you just
took a swing and the ball ended up in
the hole
you know be fun for a few days you can
get on tv
but it the game would not be any fun uh
so it's
failure you know and i wouldn't even
consider them failures but
they're mistakes or whatever you want to
call it they're they're part of the game
and in the end you know you go on
and we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make plenty more
and then you know the babe ruth and
you know for a long time it subsequently
got eclipsed by
a few fellows but uh he held the record
for strikeouts
you know so the of the record for home
runs and was highest play baseball
player until
the modern era came along so it's it's
part of the game if you take big swings
you know you
you may you may you're going to miss
sometimes got students last week 160 of
them from harvard
south dakota state i just tell them try
to find your passion and you know i mean
may not find it the first time but you
know don't sleep walk through life find
something that
you really enjoy doing if you can do it
and not you know
not everybody's lucky enough to be able
to find that but it's it ought to be
your goal but
to make ten dollars a week more doing
something that you don't feel good about
compared to something you'd feel good
about you know make the change bill said
something i thought was really
interesting he said
the thing you do obsessively between age
13 and 18 that's the thing you have the
most chance of being world class at yeah
bill said his one thing was coding what
was your one obsession well i was pretty
interested in investments now bill and i
his father many years ago right after we
met
had us a group of about 20 write down on
a sheet of paper one word that they
thought accounted for their
success and bellow guy who may only met
twice
didn't know what the other one was
writing down we both wrote down the same
word which was focus
and he was focused on software i was
focused on investments and it
it it gave me a big advantage to start
very young there's no question about it
what are the key indicators you look for
within companies before making
an investment well i look for something
that does give them a motor rob
we have a company called sea's candy out
on the west coast these candies
box chocolates if you give a box
of sea chocolates to your girlfriend on
the first date
and she kisses you we own you
you know we we can raise the price
tomorrow i mean you'll buy the same box
you're not going to fool her out with
success so the key there is the response
you do not want to go home on
valentine's day and say to your
wife or your sweetheart preferably
they're the same person
you don't say here honey i took a low
bid it doesn't work
price is to a degree is immaterial
if you've got a economic castle people
are going to come and want to take that
castle away from you
and you better have a strong moan you
better have a nightmare castle that
knows what he's doing
if you tell me who your heroes are i can
tell you how you're going to turn up to
quite an extent
by this point in life and i i i have
been extraordinarily lucky
and that none of my heroes ever let me
down i mean i the ones i
came up with uh throughout their lives
that i've never felt that i've been let
down in any way with it
number one was my dad and and and uh
had a huge impression on me um my wife
who is heroes
is one of my heroes i mean she is uh you
know in terms of
she's taught me a tremendous amount and
and never seen anybody any better with
human beings than
she is and uh you can you know yogi bear
again so you can you can
observe a lot just by watching and
i you know i watched my dad and i've
watched her
and uh i had a professor ben graham
uh back at columbia and had a huge
impact on me so
i have been lucky in that i've had
terrific heroes and they they haven't
let me down and and uh
that that takes you a long long way i've
gone through one or two periods where
we're kind of tough in life but not any
i mean every
everybody had had that but but having
the right heroes will take you right
through it
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you watch a video and you just get
motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action but
when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when
and how you're gonna do it your number
jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of
action for the next week put it down the
comments below so you can follow through
and i can celebrate you in business i
swing at easy pitches
i stand there at the plate and if i like
pictures
one inch above my navel right in the
center of the plate
i can wait and wait and wait because
there's no called strikes you know
as long as that bats on my shoulder
nobody's calling a strike if the
pitchers throws me general motors at 36
ibm at 82 microsoft at 25 and i don't
swing
it's not a strike it's not a hit either
but it's not a strike
only when i swing is it a strike so i
wait for easy pitches
i wait for things i understand they're
exactly in my sweet spot
if you want some incredible motivation
from tony robbins check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you want to know the difference
in people's lives it all comes down to
what are the things that are must for
you versus shoulds so let me tell you
this we said to have an extraordinary
life you gotta have an extraordinary
psychology right